février 1962 france a quitté le havre
pour sa première traversée vers new york
gagnant la haute mer le navire non de
316 m et déplaçant 56 mille tonnes
atteint rapidement sa vitesse de
croisière
si certains passagers apprécient malgré
le vent le soleil des ponts promenade
les autres préfèrent à l'abri des ponts
couverts entouré des attentions du
personnel se livrer au confort des
chaises longues ou aux joies du footing
sur la passerelle le commandant a donné
l'ordre à la machine d'allumer les huit
chaudière spécialement étudié pour une
consommation minimum de mazout
elles vont transmettre au turbo
alternateurs la puissance nécessaire
pour développer 160 mille chevaux et
atteindre une vitesse de 35
à
ces machines fournissent aussi le
courant électrique
c'est par ce tableau véritable centre
nerveux du navire que passent tous les
circuits électriques un seul homme de
quarante surveille le bon fonctionnement
dans toutes les parties du navire sur le
france où tout a été conçu pour le
confort et le bien-être le personnel de
la salle à manger des premières classes
achève la mise en place des tables pour
le déjeuner c'est dans ce décor que les
passagers trouveront la meilleure carte
de tous les navires actuellement en
service
la classe touriste qui peut accueillir
15 cents passagers est aussi bien
aménagé et décoré que la première place
des tapisseries d'aubusson orne le
fumoir
dans le grand salon des sièges
confortables un bar et une véranda
permettent à chacun de goûter les
plaisirs qu'ils préfèrent
et pendant que ce couple américain se
détend dans le calme de sa cabine
climatisée
les enfants qui ont aussi leurs locaux
personnels suivent passionnément les
aventures de guignol en mai
oui
dans le salon de lecture des premières
classes oeuvre d'un grand décorateur
parisien trois mille volumes sont
offertes aux amateurs de lille le
déjeuner a été annoncé et les passagers
se hâte vers leur talent
[Applaudissements]
un toast au succès du navy amérique est
proche
les messages radio affluent le france a
maintenu sa vitesse près de 33
et bientôt en bronze light le bateau feu
qui marque la limite des eaux
territoriales américaines
le grand pavois hisser la statue de la
liberté va être passée 8 février 1962 9
heures du matin l'horaire a été
strictement respecté france entre dans
l'hudson river et va recevoir laquelle
inoubliable que new york réserve aux
grands navires qui pénètre pour la
première fois dans son port
un supporter des dizaines de bateaux
saluée par les sirènes survolée par des
hélicoptères au milieu de gerbes d'eau
des bateaux pompes france poursuit sa
marche triomphale vers son quai
d'accostage
[Musique]
pour les passagers c'est
l'émerveillement de découvrir ou de
revoir les célèbres gratte-ciels de
manhattan
à l'heure dite le navire atteint enfin
le quai sous les acclamations des new
york
on a répondu aux espérances mise en lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]